And welcome back.
(audience cheers)
We're here with Joseph Gordon-Levitt.
And that was a clip from his new show,
Super Pumped: The Battle for Uber,
which is one of the best shows I've seen in so long.
Oh, thank you.
You founded this company called Hit Record.
Will you please tell us about it?
Okay, so, well, it started before it was a company at all.
It was just this thing I was doing
together with my brother.
Brother, yeah.
Yeah, when I wanted to make little art
different than show business.
Like little songs or stories
or videos of stuff I was making.
And he helped me set up a little website
to put it on there.
And then this community started forming on the website
and we all started making things together.
And so now it's grown a lot and it's a company
and we still make things together.
And we've made big shows and won awards
and published books and stuff like that.
Well, since you bring people together through art
I was wondering, we've never done this before on the show.
We could do a little project of our own, ready?
Okay, I'm ready.
Okay, it's Masterpiece in a Minute.
(Joseph laughs)
(clock ticks)
(audience cheers)
All right, it's very simple.
We're gonna go for one minute.
Put the clock on and together we can draw one another.
Okay.
We have one minute.
I'm gonna draw you and you'll draw me.
Okay.
All right, ready, one, two, three, go!
Who is an actor that you wish you could work with again?
An actor I wish I could work with again, Don Cheadle.
Oh, I love him.
I did a movie with him and Zoe Deschanel.
It was actually, when I met Zoe
before we did 500 Days of Summer together, on Manic.
Oh, the best movie ever.
Oh, thank you.
Now you played an extra terrestrial
and I was in an extra terrestrial movie.
Do you believe in extraterrestrials?
Mm-hmm.
That's it?
What are you wearing on your shirt?
Wait, I'm too busy drawing, horses, okay.
Oh my God, details.
Okay, oh God, 20 seconds left.
Do you consider yourself
20 seconds, oh God, okay.
a hopeless romantic in real life?
A hopeless romantic, yes, absolutely, of course.
'Cause romance is really like, what else is there,
if there's not romance, right?
Oh God, I know your family.
Your whole story is so beautiful.
Okay, Inception was about hacking into dreams.
What's the strangest dream you've had lately?
The strangest dream I've had lately?
The scary ones have spiders.
Oh, okay, thank you.
Oh sorry, god darn it.
I'm drawing a big heart.
What do you think
of mine, Joseph?
I'm drawing how big
your heart is.
(Joseph laughs)
(audience cheers)
Oh my God, oh my God.
Here's my real one.
And I have a heart too.
Why do I have one tooth?
What am I a baby?
That's all I had time for.
Do you imagine me as like a 13-month-old?
Is that what this is?
(Joseph laughs)
A little bit.
Okay.
I don't know, I had only time for one tooth.
Okay, I see you ran outta time.
You had to ask the questions.
I didn't want you to be toothless.
Yeah.
One represents all 25 incisors.
No, one tooth means I'm toothless.
You could've just left out the teeth
and then no one would notice.
Okay, here, does this make it better?
Pretty good, right?
(audience cheers)
(pen scribbles)
Oh, okay.
(audience laughs)
(paper crinkles)
(Drew laughs)
That is so much worse.
Why did you cross it out?
Now I'm missing a tooth.
(laughs) Keep going.
Okay, that's much better.
Joseph Gordon-Levitt.
Yes, Drew Barrymore?
I mean, as if we
(paper cracks)
just couldn't all love you more.
Oh, thank you, Drew.
Phew, okay, Super Pumped: The Battle for Uber,
airs Sunday at 10:00 PM on Showtime.
Get on the fear, and we'll right back.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪